welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz and today i'm delighted
to be joined by
sane walters who is a senior manager
based in amsterdam
for source group international sane has
worked in recruitment for over five
years
initially starting her recruitment
career as a rhetoric
before then taking the leap into tech
recruitment
where she continued to progress her
recruitment career from consultant
to then principal and to now senior
manager
sane is extremely passionate about
offering a
best-in-class recruitment experience and
service to
all of her customers and she's now
leading a team growing a team and
building
the sgi brand on the ground in amsterdam
sane thank you for coming on the podcast
thank you for having me
really excited and looking forward to
this one and where we always like to
start is
is the million million dollar question
really which is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
that's a very interesting one because as
you know i started my career as a rec
director and you sort of get
told what a group recruiter looks like
and what you need to target
i shall say and i remember when i
started many many years ago it was very
much you need to look for people who
were
competitive and money hungry or money
motivated
very driven potentially had sales
experience
whereas if you look at me i've had none
of that i've never played
football or any competition sports i
didn't have a sales job before
recruitment and
although i like money it's not the
ultimate driver in life
um and actually if you'd asked me today
i'd say it's very different and i'd say
it's
a lot more about the skills are building
relationships
um everyone could do one deal everyone
could do two deals
but can people do 10 deals in the same
clients it's that adding
value and i think you get that through
knowing what you're talking about and
adding value to people
and making that relationship a lot very
different from here's a cv
and a lot more to that trusted advisor
as a recruiter
yeah i love that so let
obviously let's just start at the
beginning here because how the hell did
you end
up in in doing rector out i can see
obviously you did your masters in
in liverpool uh yeah so so
how did you end up in rec to wreck how
did that happen yes so i
did a bachelors i did a master's in law
as part of that second masters there was
an exchange program to liverpool
i did that i graduated back in belgium
had no clue what to do with my life
i had an offer to do a phd and teach at
a uni and i had an offer for a law firm
and i was like what am i going to do for
like next 50 years
and i did what all girls do and i looked
at my dad and i said how do i pick a
career and he said it needs to give you
the fire in the belly
and neither of them gave me that fire um
so i then delayed my career and i went
to study again
in liverpool had to tell mom and pops i
was gone again for a year
and in there i sort of uni was only two
days a week and i wanted to make my own
living well want to do hat to
um and one of the jobs that was
advertised was german speaking
recruitment consultant associate
whatever it was i had no clue and the
interview lasted
four and a half hours uh
yeah i really thought i was the harvey
specter of the world back then
um and it was a ballsy interview and at
the end of it they said do you actually
speak
german and i was like um they said do
you speak dutch and i was like yes
that i can do and i became dutch
associate recruitment consultants
and two weeks in i was like i'm
recruiting recruiters
is that a job and that's how i found out
i was a regular wow that's
i love that story i guess uh one of the
things that we're gonna
do over the coming months and i'd i
would just be good just to just focus on
this very quickly
before we start unpacking it unpacking
this recruitment story but
one of the things that we're going to do
over the couple of months is just um do
some specific
episodes on sort of um focus on helping
grads
and graduates because i think there's a
lot of stress
in that period i never went to
university i did a levels and then
i had no idea what i wanted to do but i
knew i didn't want to go to university
with something
i wasn't sure that i was going to enjoy
um so i guess just on that really
quickly you mentioned that your dad's
advice was
go for something that makes you far in
the belly i'm sure you've met plenty of
graduates now
during the time where you are now when
you're director at light
what's your sort if i'm listening to
this and i'm someone that
is graduating this year or is still on
that part like would your advice be to
me do you think
i i definitely advise you to if we could
take one step back and you're still
studying i would say go do internships
go to as many internships as you
possibly can and try
do things like offer your services for
free for for three days or something two
different companies in different
industries
because i did that during my law
studies and i realized this is
absolutely not what i want to do
which was a bit of a shame five years in
but it felt
so negative right you're always dealing
with problems
and i was like oh god no this is not for
me
so i really say go and experience as
many things as possible because you are
100
right a lot of uni studies do not
prepare you for the real life
um and i think that might be a bit of a
flaw in the educational system but you
choose something at an age of which you
think yeah that's kind of cool
i'd go and do that now you get a lot of
theory about it but you never experience
what it's like to be in that job
yeah yeah that's such great advice
because
i mean imagine obviously the other path
that you could have done is you could
have had that
you could have obviously got yourself a
job been on a good salary
good benefits and then all of a sudden
there's all these things that you could
lose
when you work out and realize wow this
actually isn't something i'm going to
enjoy but i've done five years i've
now got this salary there's a lot more
to walk away from then
isn't that yeah yes and also i think
also if you
think about the amount of pressure as a
society we put on graduates we say
you're studying and it can be something
else economics which you could do a
million things with rather a business
degree whatever that might be
and then we basically say let's say you
the first job doesn't work out
okay you've spent six months of
something that's not going to be your
career
you add so much pressure to that
individual because then the next job
must be it
and if that's not it then that person
already has two things on their resume
that didn't work out whereas actually if
you take a step back
can you blame them because a business
degree
what is that even business what does
that prepare you for could be
so many different things how can you
blame a young individual for not
immediately finding the right thing
kudos actually for having the courage to
say this is not for me and for walking
away
yeah yes it's it's it's complex isn't it
but i think yeah i just wanted to ask
you that so thank you for sharing that
so
we're i'm always curious like what how
would you describe your first two years
then before you went into then tech
recruitment
and left rhetoric like oh obviously
like there's some of the rest that i
know
um are recruiters like are we horrible
to rectorex
oh oh god what did you experience what
was it like
i would say anyone i basically i've made
my first boss the proposal
to run a grad academy and that i would
hire anyone at double the salary after
six months
because if you survive rec direct for
six months
you could do any industry it's
so hard because first of all
good recruiters if you're going to head
hunt them you have to head to them
through the office line and your head
hunting recruiters
they know what's happening right good
recruiters can't speak with you at two
o'clock in the afternoon
you need to speak with them before work
at your own lunch
or after work because most recruiters
don't finish at six
on the dots and if you're a rec direct
that means you don't finish
at all right but also a lot of
recruiters
play although that we say always don't
take a counter offer
as a rec direct i've experienced it
multiple times that recruiters do
not use rector x but use rector x to get
a higher salary
and to actually stay where they are um
it's tricky to i don't want to call it
play the game with someone who's a
player already
but it does yeah i'll go in yeah
you're selling someone their own trades
basically and it's um
it's very hard also with sales people
are proud people
and billings do get inflated when you
speak with
candidates it might be a bit more than
it turns out to be on a reference check
because everyone's quite proud of what
they've done
um it is tricky yeah
but it made honestly it was a great
introduction into it recruitment because
i was like
especially because i did perm and i'm
doing contract and i was like oh these
people want to speak with me
they want a new job well that's amazing
they are honest to me about their salary
because they want me to get them a
higher salary it's a
very different experience but it taught
me so much
yeah i can imagine so to
sort of wrap this part up then i guess
for people listening
because i'm sure you've sort of had to
take some of your own
advice and you've learned a lot of
things along the way but like if i'm
listening to this and
i am considering a um career move in
recruitment
and i think it can always be really
there's one obviously when you're sort
of
a couple of years into your career
there's a lot to lose right particularly
if you're a contract recruiter
like you're potentially losing
relationships blah blah blah so
i guess for someone that's listened to
this that is
does have the right motivations they're
not in it to try and just get more money
at their current
business but i really that really want
to progress their career and
maybe want to go into a new sector or
and
want to be in a better environment like
what what would be your advice
to me to make sure what some of the
things that you would tell me to do to
really make sure i have the best chance
of finding
the right company you know like just i
guess just some advice on that i think
would be great yeah i think i think
there's a couple of things because when
i make my last move i was
earning very well and it's indeed as you
say you have that thing with
i'm gonna lose all my clients i'm gonna
have to do it all again
and i'm gonna start from zero as a
recruiter you need to have faith
in your skills that you can transfer
them
your skills are yours you can do that
again
this client is your client because they
picked up the phone on a certain day you
called them
you could do that with other companies
and the money will come again
you need to sort of accept that and then
i would say
when you're gonna look for a new company
when i did my interview process
i very much said i'm gonna first of all
these are my timelines
i'm not resigning before a certain date
i'm not making a decision before a
certain date
if you want to offer me beforehand you
can but you aren't going to close me
because this is a very important career
decision
and then also said i am going to ask
members of staff
what the biggest problem is in this
company
and if they tell me there's nothing and
everything's rosy
you're out so i sort of made it my
process
yeah and actually um sgi was the
only company where employees were so
upfront to me about what was there and
what wasn't
and i was like wow they had the attitude
of
without retro sales job but in general
you want to find a company that says
we want you to know everything there is
to know so that on day one there are no
surprises it is exactly what you think
it's gonna be
because at every company there's
something there's always something
and you better uncover what it is
beforehand rather than on day one or two
or 20.
i would say those two things except that
where you are you will get there again
and higher or better
and truly take your time don't be rushed
you you set the expectations and you
find out what the company
is and what it isn't yeah i love that
question
what what are the current challenges or
problems that you have in your rate yeah
and i guess final bit on this
i think will be useful for people is how
many people also depends on the business
but like
how many people would you really
recommend people
trying to meet a recruitment business
before like they make some sort of
decision you know i feel like you
definitely want to meet more than
just a business owner if it's a small
group i don't know like what what
and obviously there's nuance and context
here but typically
how many people do we want to be meeting
to have a good grasp of what we're
getting ourselves into
five yeah either more i'd always said
business owners do you understand where
the business comes from and culture
obviously and it sounds obvious but it
isn't always who's going to manage you
because they're going to put
the hiring person might be the director
and they might put the team leads above
you you want to know that
can you work with them and you'd also
want to meet at least one preferably
two peers and then one person who just
started
yeah that's great that's really great
advice thank you for sharing that
so how um how was the transition then
into
tech recruitment what what what was it
what was that like was it was it
daunting what were the things that
you had to learn quickly what was that
transition like
i remember saying very arrogantly this
feels like a walk in the park
um because what breaks a wreck your
process has to be
super tight if you miss one step if you
don't do
one call you also learn to not have
whatsapp relationships with candace but
always always everything on the phone
and it's sort of that because my process
was so
tight and so strict i was like oh and
these freelancers want to work with me i
did my first deal in week three
um which is great wow yeah but it was
and i was a bit like i've got an often
candidate says he wants it and i
literally asked
does that mean i've done a deal now
because i was unsure that that was the
way it worked
um i do the biggest challenge for me was
suddenly not being an expert in my field
suddenly not knowing what i was talking
about
because as a resurrect you work for an
agency yourself you know what life is
like
you know the pros the cons you can talk
about things
but on day one i was allegedly i was a
data specialist
and i was like i know nothing more about
data today than i did yesterday
i have no clue what i'm looking for and
i found that was the
the hardest part i'd say yeah yeah and
and i hear that a lot so where where
what's your advice for people that would
experience and feel that like where like
one
i guess two things really one what do
data specialists or sort of people that
have a certain focus like what do you
feel
like they need to be an expert in
because i always say to recruiters when
i'm talking to them about their brand
and content
because one of the worries that they
have is talking about things that they
aren't
extremely competent and then i always
have to remind them that you don't get
paid to do the job
of the people that you're supporting
right and you're never going to be as
competent as them
so one how did you start um what do you
believe
make someone an expert or what should
recruiters listen to this focus on being
an expert in
and then two yeah where did what did
your journey of like
learning and becoming more of an expert
what did that look like because i feel
like people could benefit from that and
how did you learn more about the
industry that you are now supporting
yeah so on the um on the first day i
stayed late
which uh seems to mark my recruitment
career and i literally
googled every blog paper article i could
find
printed it all off went home stayed up
very late
read through it and sort of i would say
definitely in the first six months
i read so much data for dummies and
what is power bi what is tableau loads
of what is
youtube videos and full dummy videos
and i'd say i still do that i still try
to learn as much as possible about new
things
one of the things i would recommend
every rt recruiter is read the book
the phoenix project because it shows you
it's about a project
which is going terrible and it gives you
a
very good idea of who your stakeholders
are what is the difference between the
business and our team where do they meet
who signs off budgets where does data
come from
how does data get visualized why is it
important but also
when does a hire get approved when do
people hire externals when do they hire
more employees
who says so um which gave me a really
good insight in truly understanding my
stakeholder and really understanding the
process
i completely agree with what you say is
that i can't do a data visualization
shot myself i would have no clue
which buttons to hit but i do know that
when my client tells me i wish we'd have
insight
a couple of weeks ago it happened they
said i wish we had some insight we've
got this huge excel
and we don't really know what it means
that's oh you need
someone to visualize it what tools you
have oh we've got tableau license
somewhere great let's get you
project proposal for a tableau developer
to come and set this up which
which metrics do you want to see which
things you want to click into i can
advise on that i can't build it myself
but i know what it looks like and i can
identify when someone needs it
and i think those things see you don't
need to become an expert but definitely
google the how to and for dummy videos
and read books such as phoenix projects
yeah i like that that's great so
let's talk about um it's obviously
started obviously in you then obviously
craigman from wrong so when you started
the company before sui it was in london
and then you moved
close to home home for use belgium right
and then you moved over to
um amsterdam um obviously continued
building out
that market i guess look we can cross
over here with uh sgi and your previous
employer but
one of the things that i wanted to ask
you was like is
so i've worked with a number of um
recruiters that operate in
um amsterdam with brexit and everything
like what
like is amsterdam becoming the new
london like what
what what's going on here what's your
view on this obviously there's been
quite a few big brands that
have taken the head office to amsterdam
out of the uk like
i don't know what's your sort of um the
nuances that you understand and the
context that you have like how are you
feeling about this amsterdam market
yeah i think the mca market you're
absolutely right a lot of companies are
coming here
some are unaware because contracts
regulations are very
different to for example belgium or
germany or the uk
um yeah which companies aren't always
aware of when they come here
for example there's this you have to if
you work here you pay tax here you can't
just invoice with your ltd
and whatnot and a lot of companies are
unaware of all these very strict rules
about dba contracts whatever things
um so it's a bit of a journey you take
them on with you as a recruiter to also
say
great yes there is a lot of talent yes
there is an airport and you can attract
talent from the outside
there's also rules to make that more
attractive in the netherlands the
government also supports by the way
companies coming over here by giving
them certain tax breaks
um but you have to do it by the rules of
the country
so i would always recommend to work with
a local recruiter who does
and understand the compliance and
everything that goes along with it
so you are and i hope i'm not you can
obviously work with uk recruiters i
don't know what to say you can't but
what i say is
a recruiter who just does anything and
everywhere will
find it very hard to do a one-off
placement in the netherlands because it
gets so complex
a uk recruiter who does netherlands all
day long will understand the ins and
outs of it but i definitely say always
work by a local entity
and that's where a lot of clients have
surprises sometimes because they are
unaware of it
but i do see that it's becoming a lot
more of an uh expat driven city as well
a lot of people are moving here it's
very international it's very
multicultural
and i see why because it's always
something to do it's it's
at the same time it's this small village
feel because a lot of people know each
other and it's really not that big
yeah so if it's okay if we can just
focus on this for a second and then i'm
really keen to go into
your journey of um building your market
from scratch and these things so
on amsterdam sometimes i get quite a few
messages from recruiters who
are really motivated to take their
career um
internationally right so if that is into
mainland europe or
to the states or whatever so i guess
you're talking a bit about there in
terms of like some of the laws and
understanding all of that
putting those aside for a second what
what do we need to understand if we're
going to start recruiting in the
amsterdam market or that sort of region
what do we need to
what are the nuances that we need to
understand that probably brits will
probably learn the hard way
like of interest like in terms of what
comes up for you with that
two things on the client side they want
to see you face to face
there's very little clients that will do
business with you just from over the
phone
the minute you get in front of someone
and we we call it having a coffee
that is the go-to thing that's when
partnerships begin that's when your
client starts to trust you
so get in that facetime and then the
other thing with
candidates is something that does go
against what a lot of british agencies
tend to teach people is can this want to
know your margin
clients want to know your margin and
they want you they want to be able to
feel good with it and you need to be
able to justify it
and actually if you're secret about it
it will always backfire
because candidates and clients you need
to understand that you're a third party
to that relationship
and if you're not adding value you're
not on site with them and
although your contract says do not
disclose commercial information
candidates will always find out what
their rate is always
and if clients find out that you're
underpaying a candidate you're finished
it's done
which really goes against the
traditional oh we're worthy of a margin
because you also need to be able to
explain it and that's why i really
keep on hammering on that on that
relationship building that added value
because if you do
that you're never going to have an issue
yeah i mean you obviously part answered
it there but my next question was what
what the brits get wrong when building
an amsterdam market
that you hear on the other side of
candidate i don't know what see we've
talked
spoken about yeah there's no sort of um
cloak and dagger here people
um people want directness people want up
front
and an honesty and like look this is
what will be met like so
that's that relationship building but
where else do you see
brits go wrong in trying to yeah conquer
the amsterdam market
i would say the candidate experience and
feedback because the market
of local candidates is relatively small
and if you you can't just put someone
forward never talk to them again forget
to give them feedback whereas you might
get away with that in other markets
you will have to call that candidate
again if you stay in your market for
longer than a year
there will come another point where that
candidate is suitable for the job you've
got and available
and that not giving feedback or not
telling them what the process is not
keeping them in the loop
really that relationship building also
with candidates something that i see
go wrong yeah so it's a long term
mindset really double down on
relationships
okay all right amazing um and actually
also on this
do i need to do i need to do i need to
speak dutch is that important
or can i get by like or do i get extra
brownie points
like i don't know yes can i if i'm
brutally honest i'd say
before copit uh
you could get away with it depending on
the clients you target
you're always better off if you speak
dutch even if it's just to be able to
introduce yourself to be able to you
know
ask a bit of dutch things whatever it is
but you have a big advantage
before covert it was easier then covet
hit and you notice that recruiters who
are already finding it difficult
found it even more difficult and i do
think that as an english speaker
you have to work twice as hard it's 100
possible
but you are a bit behind and you have to
work a lot harder
yeah yeah okay and then final point on
this i promise
with that in mind thinking people
listening
look i guess are we saying you're gonna
have to be affluent in dutch
absolutely not but i think what you're
sort of communicating here is that
there will be things if you go above and
beyond and show that you're trying to
understand the culture the language
these something that goes a long way so
i guess
what what what would people appreciate
is it if i really sort of really give it
a go of trying to introduce myself
in dutch and i don't know what like what
where should i
i guess just try and you know give it a
real go and what people would appreciate
do you think
i think it's definitely the charm of the
you know the effort into
introducing yourself a nut and politely
asking is it okay if we switch to
english
but also other things like the fact that
you have terms that are in dutch
goes a long way because you're trying to
adapt to the market
the fact that you understand compliance
process goes a long way the fact that
you
try to pronounce companies by their
actual name
rather than some english mumble jumble
will go a long way
and you and and i think the laying out
your process and saying that i'm going
to be honest with you
this is who i am this is what i do this
is what we're going to do together
i will always give you feedback i just
have a good and structured process and
then
your levels i would say right i love
that cool thank you for sharing that so
let let's go into the sort of journey
that you're you're on with sgi then so
from what i can see
you join them january 2020
um yeah yeah yeah yeah actually
yeah so so yeah before before obviously
everything changed right so
obviously just for context obviously you
obviously then
obviously were working for your previous
company in amsterdam
doing contract doing uh that and then
you've gone to sgi
and then you're building out their data
market from scratch
is that right and you're the sort of
first person in the ground for for that
brand of business
okay yeah um so obviously and then
you're
going towards sort of a year and a half
in now right into that journey and i
know you said that you've just hired two
people and
things are going in the right direction
yeah yeah definitely
definitely okay yeah let's talk about
let's talk about how this started then
like how how the hell did you approach
this
which i'm sure at the time felt like a
really exciting challenge
an opportunity but no doubt some sort of
mountain that you knew that
you're gonna have to climb up so what
what was the strategy
what was like talk to us about the
thought process and how you was gonna
start building this market from scratch
and where you started
i think there's always two things on the
one hand you want your compliance to be
done your legal entities and everything
but on the other hand if there's no
money coming in then what's the point of
having compliance set up
so you always want to juggle those two
things
i'm a very structured person so i had a
sort of road map mapped out of how to do
business in the netherlands
what do you need for it and it's
literally uh you know registering with
the chamber of commerce getting a bank
account
getting local contracts all those things
you have to do whilst in the
day-to-day also drumming up new business
because obviously there's a relationship
clause
so you've got to start over again you've
got to also
inspire other people to go to clients
together with you
and ensure candidates that you are a
trustworthy partner
even though we've not done this before
and this entity might be new
so i think it's very much about the
combination of working structures and
rolling with the chaos
i'm making that magical combination yeah
making it work okay so what
what was the talk to us about people or
p i'd say the most popular area that
people want to know more about and learn
from and
hear how people sort of approach it and
their tactics and these things
is definitely new business so you
mentioned drum up new business there
talk to us about how you approach that
was it right you did some market mapping
you knew sort of where where the types
of businesses that you felt like you
could support
um talk to us maybe about what how did
you identify the niche that you was
going to go after
and then how did we then start
communicating to these people was it
straight getting on the phone was it i
don't know talk to us a bit about that
yeah it's um interesting because when i
was at my previous company
data was a lot of on-prem data and
actually while i
made the move to sgi a lot more data
became cloud which also meant that
it was nicer for me because i didn't
have to worry that much about my
non-compete because actually my market
had already shifted
and by its nature i was no longer doing
on-prem stuff i was doing
clouds and it really became about the
again i can't say it's not adding value
understanding where there are cloud
projects understanding where you can
truly support them and i think if you
move away from a recruiter from
hey where else are you interviewing so i
can go and nick that job and backfill it
without you
and generally go to are there any
businesses where i can add value that
are currently struggling
and i can go and make a difference it's
such a different approach to pd
and it will really really help you
because you're truly doing it with the
intention to help someone else
my previous boss said to me if you help
candidates and clients all the rest will
follow
and he couldn't be more right the whole
premise of idea
of recruitment it sounds a bit upside
down that helping people because we're
here to do sales
but actually if you help people by
helping them if you understand how you
can help someone achieve their
deliverables
make their project a success especially
in covet
how can you make that work then all the
rest will follow
and that happened also through
organizing webinars
for example writing blogs putting
content out there
i've got a community on linkedin where i
actively give
information to it's no
trust buy people need to know you they
need to trust you and then they will buy
from you
and if you built that and at sgi i did
get time to build that up
properly then things will come in bd
turns around
and suddenly jobs come to you because
you're the person who's helped other
people and that goes around the market
very quickly
yes so that was going to be my next
question and you sort of
mention it there because i was sort of
where my mind went and what people might
be thinking was well
if i haven't got a sort of candidate
with the right skill set then what else
can i help them with
you know and just sort of playing
devil's advocate there so i understand
this
i need to give value and i need to help
so i guess
how talk was a bit about that journey of
how did you then come to
i don't know what what did sort of help
first look like was it signed
sort of sharing content on linkedin was
it first webinars i don't know talk to
us a bit about
the other things that i guess recruiters
maybe sometimes miss or don't understand
that they can help their their markets
with and and how you did that and
achieved that
yeah the easiest thing that everyone can
do is i'm sure you've got a candidate
you get along with really well
and that candidate can do with a bit
more
market exposure so for example you do an
interview with the candidate
and you post that on linkedin you can do
it as a video you can do it as a blog
where that candidate shares their highs
their lows tips about certain projects
whatever it is because i'm not a content
expert in cloud for example but my
candidates are
next thing you can do is a webinar where
simply the candidates will explain about
past projects and what the tips are the
dues don'ts
and because you're organizing it you're
helping the candidate get more market
exposure
but you're also helping you can invite
prospect clients into it
who you know are going to go to the
clouds and suddenly
you go from being nobody to being oh
you're the person who organized all
those webinars about clout
can we have a chat afterwards you
message people
with if you have any questions do you
like to be addressed drop me an email
and you suddenly get inbound emails with
oh we're struggling with this on the
project is that something you can
address in a webinar
as well as and i'm giving all my tips
away here but i guess it's not rocket
science
it's also the if you have any questions
at the end of the webinar drop me an
email
and the client goes actually we're
really struggling with
understanding how much we leave on-prem
how much we take to the clouds
not a problem at all let me organize a
call with the speaker of the webinar
who's now magically available for a new
project you put everyone in a call
together the speaker helps project and
before you know it you've got placements
because he's going to help that client
and you've brought the clients on
by just doing a webinar by just wanting
to help i love that yeah so
basically what you've been doing with
these webinars is sort of
bringing and you've created a space in
your market
for the important discussions and sort
of a space for people to come and attend
and learn uh
on the things that are important to them
and guess what you can add value
you can connect people you can add value
and yeah okay
i love that so obviously how how quickly
how long did it take before you started
doing business then
oh no that's
all no that's also credit too i have
some wonderful colleagues who are
already doing
engineering in belgium who already has a
few clients i'm obviously from
belgium and it's crossover there's a
very thin border
um where there's a lot of crossover
between clients and they made some
wonderful introductions for me and
through that i also got the grant
running very quickly
yeah okay fair enough so that's that
that's brilliant
so i guess so you've spoken around the
the client side i guess let's just get a
bit more practical on the
on the contract side for the people uh
listening who are
in in contract recruitment so i i uh
always did
i always did perm and from what i
understand
about contracts and speaking to people
like yourself etc is that
obviously the candidate piece is
obviously still important you have to
continue building that network and
really get good at understanding um who
has what skill sets you can do what and
get really good at understanding that
quickly
so you can act quickly but what i always
seem to understand and grasp is that
the client side winning projects getting
involved with a business that wants to
go from
five freelancers to 15 contractors or
whatever
that's like getting the opportunity to
at least speak to these companies about
supporting them achieve that
is the more harder part um is that right
yeah so
you've mentioned around helping giving
value that's obviously contributed to
that
but i guess getting real practical like
you mentioned there around
understanding sort of people um projects
and stuff like that
if if i'm a contract recruiter how can i
get better at understanding where the
projects are going to be
like do you know what i mean i guess
that's what i'm trying to ask you is
like how have you got better at
understanding
or getting the information that you need
to be the first
recruiter going hey are you gonna need
contract like do you know what i mean
how have you got better at
sniffing out these projects and stuff
for a lack of a better term
for yeah on the bd side very much
depends on
you need to be i can only experi talk
from my experience
for example i don't i rarely do aws i
mainly do the microsoft stack meaning
i've got alerts set up that when
microsoft announces a new partnership
with a company i get that in my inbox
so i know these companies actually
recently signed up
i've also made sure that i've got
partnerships through microsoft and i
understand who
their clients are so i understand where
the projects are going to happen
who's going to migrate from what there's
certain projects i would say that are
not big enough for a consultancy to do
and that they will look for freelancers
it's very good for you to understand
which ones those are and again if you
then also going to do
webinars again on very niche topics
or you're gonna do a rebecca from our
marketing's on a brilliant job in we've
got a
report coming out where we talk about
the cloud market
i can see you downloaded that so i can
reach out and say
where are you at with your project but
you can't do you have to choose a niche
and too many recruiters do everything in
development or everything in clouds or
everything in
any market and it's too big to track
choose your thing
really add value to candidates because
the ones on projects will get calls
through their own network and pick up a
lot of information
and if you know them i got a message
yesterday saying
by the way this customer is looking for
to begin their
azure project you can reach out to this
manager he knows you're going to call
i've recommended you
and it just changes because you do one
thing and you do it extremely well
yeah so obviously you hear that you hear
the phrase and recruitment niche a lot
right so in your opinion then obviously
you said how important it is
like just talk to us about your like how
would you
so if i'd if i joined your team and
you're saying look heechum
like you're going to be niche and you
have to be niche that it's important
how would you explain niche to me like
what like what is a niche in your
opinion right
because i think sometimes people are
unsure it is is neat like
is what i'm trying to think about too
niche is it too broad
so in your in your what in your opinion
like what makes a niche out of interest
i don't think that in recruitment you
always must be niche i think
if you're going to be account managing
for a specific client and you're going
to help them with as many needs as
possible or you're going to be in the
delivery role
you don't need to be nice you need to
understand the role you're working you
need to be good
at finding the right people quick i do
think from a bd perspective
if you're going to be a niche 360
recruiter then niche would be
picking a technology and you can do that
by your linkedin insights
understanding which is the technology
that most companies in my area pick a
country also a country and a technology
have hired him the most lately where are
the most palm jobs open
in what niche is that what what area is
that
you can choose a industry vertical i
personally haven't done that
i go a lot more about the you pick a
country and a tech
basically and you understand that tech
truly yeah
okay got it so you when you mention the
industry you're saying
so i could do amsterdam aws
and people that operate in
pharmaceutical
and just that you're saying i've just
done i've stopped at aws for example
rather than then potentially even okay
yeah because
the um if you're going to go the
industry you're
just to touch on dni a little bit every
pharmaceutical company let's just say
well data science right every pharma
company that's only going to hire data
scientists that
have only ever worked in pharma only get
one perspective
but if a pharma company has a scientist
who's done banking before
they get a very different view of how to
look at their data
okay so on this then i'd love to hear
your answer to this question so
what what do you believe then is the
sort of one thing
that contract recruiters need to
absolutely master
and be cons like and and be really great
at
do you think will really help them
achieve a consistent performance
and why
um consistent performance that would be
expectation management with your clients
if your clients know what to expect from
you they will come back to you
always knowing what the timeline is and
you will be able to work multiple jobs
properly every week getting coverage on
multiple jobs and therefore setting
yourself up for success
every week nice client expectation
if you get really good at that yeah okay
i like that
okay so i wanna um
impostor syndrome yes
what's been what's been your journey
with that what how's that been
yeah we touched on it on my first day at
recruitment i think that was a day that
i felt a bit like
an imposter when i had no clue what data
was
and then i think when you transition
into management you're sort of like
am i winging it here because this is a
whole new skill set
um but you overcome it through
learning your traits and learning your
role and i think you through
self-development you can get over that
feeling or i did
really so for someone so for someone
listening to this that
may have the exact same experience as
you but still
has to deal with sort of constant sort
of feelings of
have i deserve to be in this position
like
and sort of could be really
self-critical like where
talk to us a bit about that
self-development journey was there any
books that you read that really had a
real impact is there
sort of certain habits or practices that
you have that you feel was
sort of giving you that inner confidence
that um can sometimes lack in people
what yeah i read a lot of books about
four to six months and i listen to
audiobooks so
i'm all about self-development nice but
i would also say because there's so much
content out there so why don't you just
begin by asking
last three people you placed what did
you like about working with me
what would you have wanted that i would
have done and what would you want me to
stop doing
and there you will have the things
you're already doing well the positive
feedback
the thing you need to stop right now and
the thing you can develop further and i
think
ask three people very minimum there will
be a theme in there
and develop yourself within that theme
and you will feel a lot better on one
hand because you've got the feedback
and on the other hand because you can
look in the mirror and you can reflect
on it and you could do something about
it
so empower yourself basically what were
those questions again
uh what was it that you really liked
that i did
what is it you enjoyed the most in our
process what would you want it
that i would have done or the value i
would could have added and what do you
want me to stop doing immediately
i love that now what great questions to
ask to us
people that you work with awesome okay
so and what you're saying there is if
you
actively ask questions like that with
people that you've worked with you're
giving yourself an opportunity to work
out where you can improve but also at
the same time
hear from people say hey um you um
you're great at this and
yeah okay i love that that's that's
really practical that's awesome
so um talk share with me then
like so you mentioned there i really
like the way that you put the beginning
of your journey around the sort of
sort of having an organization within
the the chaos so a lot of people
um a lot of recruiters have consistently
shared over the last couple of months
how they really want practical tips
advice on like self management time
management discipline
whatever you want to call it i think
what's really shifted over the last
couple of months is how
busy people have got um is what i
continue to hear
so it's really highlighted the
importance of understanding
what i need to be spending time on
that's going to get me closer to my
outcomes and goals rather than just
doing the things that
i like to do right so would you mind
sharing like what
or you're building this business you're
now having people in your business who
i'm sure you're going to have to be
really good at yeah understanding what
you need to be prioritizing so
talks is about what does people like to
hear daily structures so like what
what does it what does your struct day
look like your typical day plan look
like i've interested
to talk about my day planner i think the
first thing is read the book david allen
get the things done
do that hundred percent david allen get
things done
yes and what you will see is that people
are busy because it's busy in your head
there's so many things in your head then
there's constant emails coming in which
crowd your head your head is for
getting ideas not for storing them busy
only means you've not addressed things
so if you read the book you understand
that you need to write a lot of stuff
down and create a system that you can
rely on
and then it becomes so my calendar is
very well organized which also means i
can't take ad hoc meetings
doesn't work there's no time blocks it
can't happen
you do need to plan for the you know i
can do meetings after six because i
block everything until six so everything
that is
crazy and things need to happen now i
cannot stay that in
after six but that sort of sacrifice are
prepared to make
map your your day out so for example you
literally say
7 30 i like to start early review
my action required list that's a list of
things i need to do
review action take and follow up it's
actions i've taken they are with someone
else did they do their job on that
at eight o'clock get my list ready who
do i need to call today
first of all what what is my action list
and that can be
my clients i need to confirm contracts
with understand if they've got budget
approved for roles
understand how my contractors are
getting on on boarding etc
then there's always half an hour booked
in for admin that's the time i
look at my email designated email time
everything that comes in over email is
not urgent even though people write
capital letters and explanation marks
if it was urgent they would call email
can always wait
and it's very important do not mistake
the things you have to do as you said
with the things you want to do
there's always going to be urgent
requests there's always going to be
things that need
now now now and everyone's had the
client that said i need cvs buy clothes
of play
and then don't connect you for feedback
for two weeks
you are human you are in charge of your
life and your calendar
if an urgent jobs come in at five
o'clock you ask your client
i know you need cvs by 12 o'clock
tomorrow but what does that mean
what happens tomorrow at 12 o'clock
because i can get you that
but understand that that implies that i
can't have my dinner with my family
tonight
and i can't go to bed at 10 o'clock
because i'm gonna be up all night
working this job
and a lot of clients then also see the
human side of the recruiter and go
oh i don't want you to work those crazy
hours actually it was more because i
would like to have cbs at 12.
what is more reasonable and you
understand what happens in the client's
world they understand what happens in
your world
and life becomes a lot better and if you
have that diary mapped out
also understand how much time am i going
to spend on the job
and map it out in your diary so you
don't spend your life resourcing
something that you should have closed
really be honest about the quality of
the jobs you've got and the time you're
going to invest in it
but block that out in your diary
everything has to be
in your diary so that you can also
tie your laptop off close it close your
emails and you know you've done what you
need to have done
and that feeling of how shall i say that
overwhelming feeling of being busy
goes away because you know you've got
time allocated to do the things you need
to do
to get your results that was very
passionate
yeah no i love that honestly that that
was great and like
so uh do you spend any time
then reviewing your weeks out of
interest do you then have a
non-negotiable time each week to sort of
look at right where am i
where am i heading do you do any of that
at all or is it always yes
yeah no no actually we've got what we
call a jobs pipeline meeting that means
every morning you're able to pull up a
report for yourself
to understand what is open what is
ongoing how long it's been on going
forward does it have cvs against it
what's the next action
and you get a very clear insight are you
on track or not are you where you're
supposed to be that week
what things have required more attention
what things need more attention
so you can review and adjust your day if
needed
yeah i love that that's awesome and then
so look i absolutely love your mindset
energy
passion for this so like talk to us
about obviously i'm sure it hasn't all
been smooth sailing
in the last 15 months talk to us about
what what have been some of the sort of
real challenges that you've had to
work through um in the last 15 months
what have been some of the the darkest
darkest periods oh um i think it's very
much the
when you're setting up something new
you've got to be honest with yourself
no you're not going to get it done in 40
hours a week it's just isn't going to
happen
um but there's also periods especially
look obviously covet hit and i think i
always say covet before covert it was
busy because you're setting up a new
market
then coveted and i was super busy to get
more jobs on to cover for the
hole that covet left or could have left
and then when
everyone realized that working for my
was a real thing it stayed super busy
because now more jobs were released
because projects were behind
so i always state this massive peak of
busyness last year
and it's very easy to not
think about yourself but to keep going
keep going keep going because i'm
setting up this new market i am doing
this and there's a million things to do
um ben milwaukee has also been on this
podcast is
it's my mentor and i asked him work life
balance
i struggle with that how even though my
fantastic planning system i do plan
away till late way too late if i'm
honest and he said the great phrase
there's own work-life balance doesn't
exist there's only life and we tend to
fill it up with work
and that was so true for me that was a
real
you're so right moment and i've had a
bit of this aha moment where
the world doesn't end if you
do if you forget to put your logo on on
the cv the first time
and you send it again the world doesn't
end the client doesn't think you're any
less of a recruiter
if you close your laptop at 7pm the
world
doesn't end projects don't go away
and that realization that actually i'm
very passionate about what i do but i'm
going to be doing this for a very long
time
clients and candice are going to be
there for a very long time if you treat
everyone with respect
nobody wants an overworked recruiter
candidates don't want to speak with
someone who's stressed clients don't
want to speak with someone who's
stressed
and that was definitely an aha moment
for me
yeah i love that i think yeah work-life
balance
i i just think it's so individual i
think to
to sort of yeah i'd think to paint a
brush where everyone should have a
work-life balance and everyone should
work
like sort of leave work at this time or
you shouldn't be thinking about work
when you're home and stuff is
it's just everyone has their own
individual sort of
feeling towards work you know i think
this would be a you wouldn't be
talking the way that you are if sort of
a lot of the a lot of your
working um life you really didn't enjoy
what you did and you was miserable and
you were sad when you got home
and you were then dreading about the
next day but yeah i just couldn't agree
with that more and i think it's just
yeah i guess what before we finish then
what i wanted to ask you was
which could tie into this is then
just women in recruitment like how how
can we get more
how can we like what's your view on look
so my
context from speaking to people like
yourself
um and other women in recruitment so
the sort of just an overview of what
i've taken in and learned
is what i think is massively changing
hopefully
but sort of maybe in the last five to 15
years
a lot of women and have found it
difficult because they've
been at a crossroads where it's like
right i need to start a family
i can't have children for ages i need to
one i for
i need to think about when i do want to
have a family but i've worked really
hard in my career
um how reasonable am i company going to
be when i come back
i'm worried about that i'm just gonna
choose career or i'm just gonna choose
family and i'll work out career right
which can sort of i feel like has had an
impact on how many then
leaders have ended up in um female
leaders ended up because they may have
had
made that hard decision where i'm
choosing career hopefully kovid remote
these things has had a real impact now
hopefully it does so that's
i think that's sort of some part of the
play and then the other thing is what
we've already discussed really where
obviously um obviously women are a lot
less likely to put their hand up for
positions if they don't feel like they
100
fit the criteria whereas guys are more
likely to
if it's 80 of the criteria right and
then there's a whole thing of them
like women not feeling um having the
imposter syndrome piece and
really struggling with that where guys i
definitely feel like i have that just as
much but maybe don't vocalize it
but like i don't know that sort of like
the paint the picture that i'm painting
but i guess what's been your journey
with this like you're someone
i feel like has invested a lot in
yourself your own mindset your own
journey like how can we inspire
more women because that's the final
piece to be fair a lack of female role
models so a lack of
yeah so i i could be listening to this
and i'm starting my recruitment career
and i haven't got a sarnae to look at
and go wow
she's done that that's amazing and she's
like if i don't have that in my company
there's no one for me to look up to as
well
how can we impact this do you think how
can we two things there's the
attracting and the retaining the first
thing is as an
industry luckily a lot of people will
tell me oh we don't do that anymore
right but first of all i think every
business owner has to read the book
rebel ideas by matthew syed to
understand why dni
is very important because if they
understand that they value it they will
do something about it
secondly we need to see how do we
attract more females as we've said at
the very beginning so this is quite a
nice circle
when i started as a record i was looking
for people who'd done you know
competitive sports or who had a sales
shop who were money hungry and you get
your typical white i always say you're a
white male essex boy
that's your hamlet right
yeah there you go classic so if we but
if you look at what actually makes a
recruiter successful
it's not because someone's money hungry
or because they know how to play
football at 14
that they can add value and build a
relationship so the trades we're looking
for are very masculine traits
the things i think make a good recruiter
are very feminine traits
so i think change in that profile is a
very very big step
what are we recruiting for and how do we
recruit what questions do we ask in our
interviews
changing that model at the beginning
allowing more women
to come in to the industry and then it's
about retaining and i think you've said
it's a very valid point about
i personally do not see how in
90 of the businesses you can be a 360
recruiter and a mother that brings the
kids to school
and still is at her desk at 8 30. i
don't see how
or puts food on the table at 6 00 pm
while you're also supposed to still be
calling clients
i don't know how you should be able to
as well as questions asked do i get my
runner book while i'm on maternity leave
do i get it back
most companies unfortunately do not have
that covered
and i think that's something where women
in recruitment apsco can make a
big big difference by creating
guidelines for how companies have to
handle it
and a lot of companies and i think
that's where the crux is saying
we don't have a policy because we've
never had to deal with it
the fear company owners because you
don't have a policy
you're also never going to have to deal
with it because women will leave your
business because they don't think it's a
safe environment as you said
what will my boss say how will they
respond
women your fight or flight and women
it's a feminine trait to flight and if
you don't know
there's uncertainty a lot of women go
internal
or leave agency recruitment as an
industry so the
we don't have it because we've never
dealt with it it's a vicious circle that
as a company you'll keep ending up round
and round around in
and it won't change your past keeps
setting your future
so as an industry we really need to
think about what are the skills
we report for example it's a very
masculine trait to peacock
two people come back for a meeting the
male recruiter will very often say
fantastic meeting this is going to be an
epic client we're going to smash it do
so many deals
whereas the female recruit might be like
good meeting
they asked us to complete an rfi
the boss will probably love the mail yes
let's smash it
right that gets celebrated let's go for
beers because we've won this big client
whereas actually the female has a very
different perspective of that same
reality
and i think it's that which skills do we
reward which behaviors do we reward as
an industry
the incentives do women care that much
about all the you know incentives that
are lined up in so many businesses
is that gonna attract or retain women or
is that
different things like flexible working
and allowing them to bring their kids to
school
and drop them off and i really think
that something as an industry
we need to change and we can change
massively and that also involves
other women speaking up i for example i
don't have a family um and i i'm not
family oriented
but i can see why it's important and i
also understand that's why within sgi
i'm a loud
voice and and the owners allow me to be
to help drive that forward
so we can make it possible for women who
do want that work-life balance
and who do want to be able to raise a
family the option's got to be there
we've got to make it possible
as a industry and as individual
companies
i love it i think that's a perfect place
to end
uh if you ask me and look before we
finish what
what are you excited about then what i
know i mentioned briefly you've just
hired two new people but what's um
what does the future look like for you
and the amsterdam part of sgi
that you're building yeah yeah sj's
motto is discover your potential and i
definitely think we're
going towards that a lot more now with
the team to discover what the potential
is of our clients
as well as to discover what our own
potential is and to really really drive
that forward
um so exciting exciting times ahead
definitely
i love it simon's been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for coming on
thank you for having me